grosse nouvelle pendant ce temps là dans
les marchés aujourd'hui tesla annonce
avoir investi 1 milliard 500 millions de
dollars américains dans le bitcoin en
janvier et le constructeur automobile
prévoit accepter prochainement la crypto
monnaie comme moyen de paiement
ces annonces ont propulsé la valeur du
bitcoin à un sommet à plus de 44 mille
dollars américains
l'action de tesla continue également de
grimper l'entreprise vaut maintenant 818
milliards de dollars américains en
bourse
le patron lui même le milliardaire et le
masque lance par ailleurs un concours
pour stimuler le développement d'un
système permettant de retirer le co2 de
l'atmosphère
il offre 100 millions de dollars en prix
la compétition s'étendra sur quatre ans
jusqu'en 2025 20 millions de dollars
seront distribués aux équipes qui auront
développé les prototypes les plus
prometteurs et 80 millions de dollars
aux trois meilleures équipes
parlons du masque avec le gestionnaire
de portefeuille simon plan de bonsoir
bonsoir
pourquoi il le musk pourquoi tout est là
et décide d'investir comme ça dans le
bitcoin mais si on prend un peu de recul
qu'on décortique faut se rappeler
récemment l'action tesla a progressé
énormément puis tout récemment la
société a émis des actions
c'est ce qu'ont fait qu'on pense notre
société est elle même surévalué dans
dans les coffres de tesla est environ 20
milliards de dollars
on renforce cette transaction l'aude 1.5
milliard ça veut dire que tu es cela a
pris un peu moins de 10% de ses
liquidités
son comparse l'investissement là sur la
valeur totale de tesla cc - 2 points 2 %
donc c'est sûr que ça fait beaucoup de
bruit cette transaction la terre marque
tous absolue c'est une grosse somme mais
en terme relatif c'est six hommes qui
est plus restreinte maintenant qu'est-ce
qui peut motiver
il ya différentes aspects
je pense que personnellement à la
liquidité l'enjeu c'est un bon coup de
marketing personnellement je trouve la
part des grandes parce que en faisant
cette transaction love ça confirme
aux consommateurs qu'ils aiment l'image
landes qui connaît classe un innovateur
qui tolèrent paul statu quo ce à
renforcer cette image d'une portion des
consommateurs s'identifier à ça et font
des déclarations en achetant ce produit
qui font partie de cette tribu là donc
ça a été vraiment un bon coup de
marketing plus en plus cette nouvelle a
fait bondir les prix du billet de cointe
sur papier savait créer une hauteur de
200 millions $ pour la société donc que
plusieurs aspects qui peuvent kerkera
probablement motivé tesla réinscrit
fondamentale derrière ça parce que
est-ce que c'est autre chose qu'un coup
de marketing
parce qu'en plus tu es cela il nous dit
on va utiliser le bitcoin va permettre
l'utilisation du big one pour des
transactions donc des achats de voitures
électriques tesla
mais ça ça m'a plus surpris c'est vrai
que la société a pas donné pour
clarifier jusqu'à ce qu'elle est
comment avoir procédé parce que regarder
un graphique du prix du bit coin de ses
très volatile donc pour un marchand peu
importe soit il accepter ce genre de
paiement à la wii ça peut se faire mais
ça doit rester très marginale parce
qu'il ya tellement de volatilité
ces points c'est pas une crypto monnaie
qui ne sera à priori tous et pour du
transactionnel
en fait la majorité des investisseurs
dans tesla pardon dans le beat cointe
aussi stratège l'apologie du capital
dans une catégorie d'actifs qui est
alternative donc peut-être l'idée aussi
c'est pas ça m'a facilité une
transaction mais peut-être même qu'il au
masque avait l'objectif est de faire un
gain sur sur les prix du bit coin comme
je dis quand on regarde là le grand
schéma des choses sa position est
relativement marginale par rapport à la
valeur totale la société mais est ce que
l'objectif est de maintenir une image
d'anticonformisme à ce tournant comme ça
vers le bitcoin donc je reviens à
l'image au marketing
compte tenu de la richesse d'une mosquée
de la richesse de cette entreprise et de
ce que ça représente dans les faits pour
porter cela est pur il une meuf est ce
que ce n'est que du marketing
je peux pas répondre pour eux mais je
pense que oui l'image à la place parce
que
garde les crypto money to bonne
révolution a toujours un porte parole
puis on regarde les crypto monnaie
jusqu'à présent dans la révolution n'y a
pas un visage donc et lentement moss
prend cette place là mais on regarde
dans les dernières semaines avec même il
en a fait des commentaires sur gamestop
d'hodgkin qui est un autre cryptome
honneur au recul quelques années lorsque
facebook avait des enjeux avec le score
scandale d'oxford analytica
régulièrement et lancement position qui
est anti etablishment donc c'est sûr que
ça vient renforcer cette image est ce
qui les influencent les autres est ce
qu'il est un facteur de changement ici
bien c'est certain que son comportement
un france les investisseurs parce qu'on
voit ces commentaires récemment propos
de gamestop giacobbi récemment beat
pointe
on a un pourcentage des investisseurs
qui vont qui vont écouter seul puisse
avoir et france et leur comportement
définitivement est-ce qu il crédibilise
le bitcoin et je pense qu'ils vont
crypte crédibiliser il ya un mouvement
de crypto monnaie qui prend de plus en
plus de place
le fait d'avoir justement publicis est
position avec beats coin oui
définitivement mais parce que d'autres
grandes sociétés qui vont suivre
j'en doute un certaine limite parce que
là la base l'actionnariat de tesla
permet ce genre d'audace d' aventure
pour d'autres sociétés je pense la
réception serait totalement différente
qu'il faut se rappeler que comme j'ai
mentionné si on est une société permet
de faire des transactions habite coin
quand gallas la volatilité sous jacente
c'est vraiment un défi
merci beaucoup simon plante très
intéressant bonne analyse au plaisir
merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit